there's a documentary that has just
filled me with delight there's a hulu
documentary many of you may know what
I'm talking about that's focused on the
Dana Carvey show and a show that you
hope you really got your start yeah I
done some work before that but that was
really I got my break danacarr V and
Robert Smigel of course your old friend
yes Robert Smigel
and Steve Carell Steve Carell was in the
cast and I remembered this very well
because I'm friends with Dana
I remember the launch of this show and
the show didn't last long no no we only
shot eight of them only seven of them
made to air mm-hmm yeah and and what's
interesting about the documentary it's
so fascinating to me is because so many
people are interested in behind the
scenes of comedy is you had this these
powerhouses of talent oh and an
unbelievable Robert Carlock who did 30
rock yeah Kimmy Schmidt with Tina
Charlie Kaufman of course internal
sunshine Sava smile yeah I'm a genius
people louis c.k and gobble people
working on it and just evaporated like a
snowball coming in from low and low
orbit yeah yeah did not last this was a
prime-time show and this was back when
prime times front time prime time gave
you they gave you a massive budget this
is a big network massive budget
unbelievable I had already worked for a
small cable show called exit 57 and we
were like you could write a sketch and
go like oh there's a jackhammer and our
producers would go do you have a
jackhammer because I don't have any so I
go over I go over there I'm living in
Chicago I get the job in New York I fly
to New York a month before my wife and
our child come out there so I'm living
about myself in the city and Robert
Smigel again the executor producer goes
hey you should pack a bag we got to go
to Florida to shoot the second half of a
three-minute sketch that we shot in New
York yeah we're just gonna shoot the
second half and Florida yeah because we
need some warm weather for it right so
okay so I go down to Florida and second
half every minute yeah that's the old
Network money yeah just doesn't exist
yet yeah only HBO has that so I go down
to Florida and I haven't talked to my
wife and there no cell phones are only
payphones this is 90 something like that
and so what we're doing is we're doing
this thing where we're doing
quote-unquote animal experiments I'm one
of the Rockefellers in the rock
Rockefeller Institute for animal
studies or something and we're just
doing things like gluing things to mice
and stuff like that not really don't get
me this was the sketch this is the
sketch premise yes and this gets premise
was we wanted to see what would happen
if you threw a horse out of here like
what happens to its heart rate yes it
has a parachute and everything right
right so they build like I I [ __ ] thee
not like a fifteen thousand dollar horse
prop yes
articulated limbs full-sized driving
overnight all the way down to Florida
we're down there waiting for it to come
they put it in an old US like army
constellation no jump a plane they fly
it over this field in Florida just for a
test drop just to see what it would look
like before we roll the cameras no
cameras rolling nobody's doing anything
and I decide I'll call my wife so I call
my wife on the phone and I hey hi yes
listen and I said listen I'm down in
Florida and she goes what are you doing
in Florida and I said well we we have to
do we have to throw the horse out of the
plane down here and she goes what horse
out of what plane I say hold on it's
coming over right now and at that moment
the horse in the plane came over and I
just start shrieking because they pushed
the horse out of the plane and becomes
transcendently clear within seconds that
the parachute is not going to open up
I'm just on the phone
I hate things that I'm being killed on
because I'm just shrieking and the horse
plummets at terminal velocity and
explodes when it hits 5000 we rebuilt it
we stayed a couple extra days and and I
said to myself at that moment I have to
get back to that network money someday
there was days PPI tells stories now we
all tell stories about the early 90s and
network TV
you remember this Andy and our writers
louis c.k was a writer on the show who's
his first job in TV and Dino sama tops
all these great people were working on
the show and every night they would pick
the most expensive restaurant in New
York order food on it and charge it to
NBC and I'd come in and they would be
cracking lobsters wearing giant bibs and
laughing we went to a Kobe steak house
in Florida on the same trip where again
we're not shooting anything yeah horse
exploded and we went to a cove a
steakhouse so we said we'll have the
surf and turf and again we don't have
that I said bring us a full lobster
dinner because a whole Kobe steak did
that yeah everybody at the table I think
that's why we're canceled yeah exactly
the entire the entire budget was gone
you